what's the strangest thing you've seen
one of us do
no pressure just wondering it's just
let's keep this going because i feel
maylene's perspective
is very different to the average female
do you have something in mind or do you
not want to say it okay okay okay well
the most recent stuff is the stuff that
comes to mind i haven't been watching
you guys record that much so i'm like
upstairs yeah recently uh well it
doesn't have to be on camera oh okay
yeah cause i will say like definitely
recording trash taste uh has made me
more self-conscious and also hanging out
with maelyn has made me more
self-conscious as well
no no sometimes i'm just sometimes i'll
just do something subconsciously like
for example i'll be sitting there and
i'll like have my hand in my sock you
know oh yeah yeah yeah which just just
happened like half an hour ago and she
was like i wouldn't say let's see it's
not weird what is cute when sydney calls
you little baby man
we're like it's like what do you have to
do my boyfriend
oh my god
i love it so much the scene of male
energy
like we're
like it was thanksgiving and then sydney
was like oh my sydney goes oh it's my
little baby and then garn i thought
garn's like this you know it is like
when your mom is like oh my
little boy is doing well
like
[Laughter]
and i'm just like whoa
sydney god she is she is my [ __ ] mom
isn't she yeah right she's just like
trying to [ __ ] embarrass me right now
jesus
no because because like i feel like
sydney sydney started saying that just
like to piss me off and then like you
you know pissed off no no no no
no because like you know when you know
when it's like you know when you're in
like a group of friends right and then
you say something ironically yeah and
then oh then you just you start saying
something ironically and then you keep
doing it and then it becomes unironic
right
little baby
no because that that came that gave him
just a random [ __ ] video like because
i remember when joey used to [ __ ] dab
everywhere i was like joey can you stop
[ __ ] dabbing everywhere yeah and then
i started doing it and i'm just like i
[ __ ] hate it you don't have to dab
all the time yeah because i made it uh
my life mission i think it was like 2016
2017 i i told myself at the beginning of
that year i'm like i'm gonna do a social
experiment every photo i upload of
myself that year i need to be dabbing
and i'm just going to see if i can like
fulfill that just to see how far i can i
did it no way yeah every single photo
every photo of me of in 2017 i'm dabbing
why would why would you do that because
it's hilarious
because seeing the comments i'm not
seeing because because all of the angry
comments of people being like why are
you doing this it was just funny to me
yeah but then when at which point did it
stop becoming ironic and you just ended
up doing it because that definitely did
reach that point yeah i think after
maybe the second time i did it
[Laughter]
i was like oh it's kind of it's kind of
fun i did think there was a year that
you did dabble on that was probably the
year then yeah that was probably the
year we met actually
impression but like i feel you're very
like heavily influenced by the people
around you in that sense because like
recently in that you know in that same
sense right like you started dabbing
ironically after i kept doing it
no but then like you know like on this
[ __ ] podcast right like you know i'm
very known to saying i [ __ ] with this
and then god started saying it
chronically as well what can i say if
you hang out with your homies enough huh
you also say a hundred percent
100 percent
echoes in my head like after recording i
go home walk into the train 100
if one of us is doing something the
other is just programming i don't think
god does stuff that rubs off on you i
feel like it's it's
only you
no no
no you just hang out with your hobbies
enough and you just i guess you just
start to mirror each other yeah i don't
know i hang out with you a lot but i
still sip like a normal human being
i mean that's just me yeah i'm
not that sure right
i don't know why i sip like that it's
just i just it's just i think it's the
sippy cups that i just can't sit like a
normal human being i don't [ __ ] know
it's like
a little baby man
that's why god likes them